tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel après
l'accident de chicago coup de tonnerre
dans le monde de l'aéronautique
washington décide d'interdire de vol
tous les décès 10 des compagnies
américaines hausse des prix + 1% en
avril et nouveau record de l'or
l'inflation s'accélère dans le monde
l'analyse d'emmanuel de la taille avec
ses partenaires européens valéry giscard
d'estaing célèbre ce soir à athènes
l'adhésion de la grèce au marché commun
bernard hinault au sommet de sa forme à
quelques semaines du tour de france il
vient de remporter haut la main le
dauphiné libéré
bonsoir tous les avions douglas dc 10 en
effet qui volent aux etats-unis dans
diverses compagnies aériennes sont
interdits de vol jusqu'à nouvel ordre
jusqu'à je suppose qu'ils soient tous
vérifiés
la décision grave importante a été prise
par l'administration fédérale de
l'aviation civile américaine et cela
naturellement à la suite de la
catastrophe de chicago qui a causé je
vous le rappelle la mort de 273
personnes
quelques minutes après le décollage
vendredi dernier l'administration
américaine a pris cette décision à la
suite des premiers résultats de
l'enquêté et auparavant le constructeur
mcdonnell douglas avait demandé aux
quarante et une compagnie qui dans le
monde entier exploite 281 décès 10 et
transporte jacques chaque jour cent
trente sept mille passagers de procéder
à des vérifications immédiate des
systèmes de fix de fixation des
réacteurs car c'est cela qui est en
cause nous le verrons dans un instant en
france la compagnie ut à exploite six
décès 10 cette compagnie est elle un
directement concernés par cette
interdiction de vol prononcé par les
américains aient quitté pour l'instant
valable que pour les compagnies
américaines
eh bien nous ne sont vos nous ne savons
pas encore nous le saurons sans doute
tout à l'heure il ya seulement deux
indications que je puisse vous donner
pour l'instant
l'aviation civile américaine a demandé
aux compagnies aériennes étrangères de
prendre une décision identique l'arête
vol des dc10 en fait l'interdiction peut
être prononcée chez nous par la
direction française de l'aviation civile
le secrétariat général aviation civile
et celle-ci indiqué cet après midi
qu'elle faisait confiance aux autorités
américaines et qu'elle se conformerait à
ces décisions
à l'heure actuelle j'ignore si cette
décision était où sera prise en france
ce que je sais c'est que la compagnie
eut t as a procédé à des vérifications
de tous ces appareils est ce qui est en
cause c'est un boulon un simple boulons
de fixation du réacteur qui s'est rompu
c'est ce que disent en tout cas les
premiers résultats de l'enquêté
américaine
ce bull ont cassé en deux a été
découvert à deux kilomètres et demi du
lieu de l'accident une fois ce simple
bull ont rompu les autres points de
fixation du réacteur aurait cédé l'un
après l'autre
un photographe amateur de chicago a pris
deux photos saisissantes juste à ce
moment là l'avion déséquilibré par la
perte de son réacteur a littéralement
basculé
n'oublions pas qu'il était en plein
décollage en pleine poussée ensuite le
même photographe a pris l'impact au sol
et l'explosion jean pierre qui tarde à
enquêter aujourd'hui auprès de la
compagnie ut à la seule je vous le
rappelle à exploiter des dc10 en france
pour bien comprendre ce qui s'est passé
vendredi soir à chicago tout de suite
après le décollage du dc 10 d'american
airlines il faut regarder très
attentivement la structure de l'appareil
vous avez d'abord en bas la partie
réacteur proprement en réacteurs general
electric de 24 tonnes et demie de
pousser mais ce réacteur vous le voyez
n'est pas fixée directement à l île est
fixé à l'ale par l'intermédiaire de
cette pièce de métal qui s'appelle un
pylône et qui est arrimée elle-même à la
voilure allèles donc par un système 2,3
vers 1 ou 2 3 attache si vous préférez
et c'est le boulon de l'une de ses
attaches qui a d'abord cédé entraînant
l'arrachement de ce premier lien avec la
voilure
puis en raison de la vitesse et la
vibration car l'avion était en train de
décoller l'arrachement progressif du 2e
puis du troisième système d'attache ce
qui a précipité le tout le pylône bien
sûr et le réacteur en tout et pour tout
environ cinq tonnes vers le bas vous
comprendrez très vite que cette masse de
cinq tonnes
partant d'un seul coup d'un seul vers le
bas à déséquilibrer l'avion et surtout
le plus grave c'est qu'en étant arrachée
2 7 l et bien une partie de la voilure
une partie de ces tôles qui sont juste
au dessus de moi et bien son parti
également entraînant bien entendu le
déséquilibre de l'appareil et les
pilotes n'ont absolument rien pu faire
car l'avion était déséquilibrée et il
était surtout trop bas 200 mètres
d'altitude environ
puisque l'appareil était en pleine
procédure de décollage et cela remet
bien évidemment à l'ordre du jour le
problème de la sécurité et des
vérifications régulières qui sont faites
à bord de tous les appareils en général
et en particulier du dc-10 comme celui
ci puisque nous l'oublions pas il y a
cinq en 1974 ermenonville un dc10
s'était écrasé lui aussi pour un
problème technique dans le cas présent
que vous a demandé le constructeur du
dc-10 mcdonnell douglas à la suite de
l'accident de chicago de faire des
vérifications particulière de vérifier
effectivement de faire la vérification
que les moteurs étaient bien suspendu
sous les ailes c'est chose faite
passé ce que nous faisons fur et à
mesure que chacun de nos avions
reviennent à sa place c'est dire que
finalement chaque appareil qui repart de
ce hangar est bon pour le service
absolument nous n'avons dur est observé
au cours de ces vérifications
aucune haine domaine bien en tout cas
nous en serons davantage tout à l'heure
monsieur antoine veulent donner son son
avis a dit que ses avions étaient tout à
fait normaux est tout à fait en état de
marche bien avant que la décision
américaine soit connu alors je répète
nous en saurons davantage tout à l'heure
j'ai appris juste avant ce journal que
le secrétaire général de l'alliance de
l'aviation civile et monsieur weil
directeur général de l'ugtt et à
tiendront une conférence de presse à 21h
pour dire si oui ou non les dc 10 sont
interdits de vol les dc 10 de lutter a
en tout cas
alerte générale contre le rebondissement
de l'inflation à un rythme accéléré dans
le monde entier en france la hausse des
prix en avril a été de 1% augmentation
des services des prix industriels de
l'alimentation du pétrole et des
matières premières ça roule c'est le
dérapage des prix atteint 3 et demi pour
cent pour les quatre premiers mois de 79
soit plus de 10% en rythme annuel et ce
retour de l'inflation à deux chiffres
comme on dit menacent le redressement
que l'on attendait du plan barre alors
qu'il va terminer sa troisième année
fatidique en septembre et sur le front
des prix les prochains mois seront
vraisemblablement médiocre ce n'est pas
un bond à 10 a reconnu monsieur monory
en ajoutant que l'on pouvait trouver une
consolation dans la réduction de l'écart
entre l'inflation en france et à
l'étranger dans le monde en effet de
l'amérique au japon les prix se sont
aussi remis à galoper du coup l'or bat
encore tous les records aujourd'hui à
paris le lingot a grimpé de 7% en
gagnant près de 3000 francs pour frôler
43 mille francs le kilo avec emmanuel de
la taille
la nouvelle escalade des prix les points
noirs sur les prix en france ne font que
refléter à dangereux phénomène mondial
signalé par toutes les bourses avec ses
trois dimensions
un retour en force de l'inflation
ressort fondamental une furieuse
bataille pour le partage des revenus et
ses risques majeurs chute de la
production et gonflement du chômage peut
être en 81 primo le retour de
l'inflation est nette en amérique du
stress pour cent et en europe
france angleterre +15 et même
l'allemagne autant en trois mois quand
même ce réveil a été provoquée par la
première véritable reprise de la
production depuis la crise pendant les
six derniers mois après avoir commencé à
redresser leur économie
la plupart des pays ont vu dès la
reprise des affaires les factures sont
bas les prix des producteurs salaires
comme le montrent les chiffres
provisoires en france et bien sûr les
prix du pétrole et
les matières premières entre 20 et 30%
ce qui a fait flamber l'or et se passer
les valeurs en bourse second tour sans
fondamental de l'impression une furieuse
bataille partout pour le partage de
l'augmentation du gâteau national entre
ses prétendants rivaux que sont les
entreprises pour les profits et les
travailleurs pour les salaires les états
pour leurs charges et les fournisseurs
de pétrole et de matières premières à la
première amélioration tous ces groupes
se sont précipités pour faire du
rattrapage ou repasser les pertes à
leurs voisins c'est ce qui a relancé la
course entre les prix et les revenus
avec ses airs d'ange et c'est gagné
tertio danger de rechute en 4 offres
comme toujours l'inflation des règles
progressivement tous les circuits vitaux
de l'économie revenus demande production
balance extérieure et se termine mal
rechute de la production et chômage ac
la reprise actuelle de la production
pourrait continuer en se ralentissant
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
mais l'inflation et le pétrole qui
oblige on en doute le gouvernement a de
nouveau tour de vis risque de faire
rebasculer l'occident dans le marasme en
80 années de campagne présidentielle en
amérique est pratiquement aussi en
france dans une bande dessinée qui est
sorti d'ailleurs pour la circonstance
des élections européennes dans cette
bande dessinée qui s'appelle il était
une fois l'europe on voit deux tombés
amoureux d'une jolie princesse
phénicienne qui s'appelle justement
europe et zeus pour la séduire se
transforma en taureau leur fils de 20,3
de crête et c'est de la crête que partie
la grande civilisation grecque
voilà pourquoi le premier ministre grec
constantin caramanlis a pu rappeler tout
à l'heure que l'europe porte un nom grec
et que sa civilisation est une synthèse
de l'esprit hellénique romain et
chrétiens certains trouveront peut-être
ce retour aux sources quelque peu
artificielle quelque peu facile en tout
cas c'est avec une certaine solennité
qu'a eu lieu à athènes aujourd'hui la
signature du traité d'adhésion de la
grèce au marché commun en présence de
monsieur valéry giscard d'estaing et des
représentants des gouvernements de la
communauté
dès son arrivée à athènes monsieur
giscard d'estaing a donnés en langue
grecque un prolongement à cette
mythologie
il est très important at il dit que la
france fille de la grèce classique se
retrouvent soeur de la grèce
contemporaine pense que vous
entendre monsieur giscard d'estaing dia
n'a ferro stone elle et nico là-haut
tonnes
havel fico frère et tissot tonnes lone
this évran pis nous allons aborder cette
adhésion de la grèce au marché commun
sous deux aspects différents
d'abord avec gérard saint paul sur la
signature elle-même puis jean françois
robinet sur les données économiques
agricoles en particulier de cette
adhésion
la signature s'est déroulée au palais
zappeion devant les neuf au grand
complet représenté par un chef d'état
donc cinq premiers ministres et neuf
ministres les affaires étrangères
cérémonie historique d'hier à constantin
caramanlis historique pour un pays qui
ne voulait pas rester en marge
une preuve de plus que la communauté
européenne n'est pas et ne veut pas
devenir un club fermé et surtout pas un
club de riches
nous y voilà la grèce espère grâce à
l'europe une véritable pluie de bien
fait et j'espère faire en dix ans ce
qu'elle aurait mis sans l'europe 30 ans
à réaliser
voilà donc aussi pour les conditions
économiques mais bien au delà du prix de
la tomate ou de la pêche fraîche
constantin caramanlis avait une autre
préoccupation celle d'arrimer
définitivement la jeune démocratie
grecque à l'europe et aussi peut-être
même s'il n'y a pas de défense commune
la protéger du danger extérieur et des
éventuelles agressions pour lui
finalement l'adhésion de la grèce
aujourd'hui et à l'horizon du 1er
janvier 1980 c'est un pari sur l'avenir
est une sorte d'assurance pour la grèce
la grèce le marché commun sont déjà liés
depuis sept ans par un accord
d'association le premier du genre signé
avec un pays méditerranéen
ils avaient pour objectif de supprimer
progressivement les droits de douane
c'est pratiquement fait dans le sens
grèce marché commun par le sens inverse
ils restent en moyenne de 15%
à partir du 1er janvier 1981 la grèce
aura cinq ans pour éliminer à son tour
ses droits de douane pour l'agriculture
il lui faudra adopter le système de la
libre circulation et des prix unique
afin d'éviter une concurrence trop vive
pour nos produits méditerranéens
français et italiens des taxes aux
frontières ou montant compensatoire cela
acceptées par nos agriculteurs seront le
cas échéant prélevés par la caisse
européenne depuis quatre ans
l'agriculture grec a cessé de croître
mais la balance agroalimentaire reste
favorable d'un milliard de francs ce qui
permet à peu près d'équilibrer la
balance des paiements avec les autres
apports de devises que sont le tourisme
et la flotte marchande
en grèce aussi l'exode rural a commencé
mais 35% de la population active reste
agricole 1 million 300 mille personnes
plus que l'exploitant agricole français
pour une surface quatre fois moins nos
agriculteurs seront ils gênés certes les
grecs produisent de l'huile d'olive du
vin des fruits et légumes mais les
récoltes sont plus précoces et nous
sommes déficitaires de presque tous les
produits grecs à l'exception des pêches
qui gêneront certainement nos
producteurs du roussillon et de la
vallée du rhône
toutefois des mesures de sauvegarde sont
prévues en cas d'excédent pour nos
éleveurs en revanche c'est un nouveau
marché qui s'ouvrent puisque la grèce
est importatrice de viande et de
produits laitiers
n'oublions pas enfin la situation
géographique de la grèce c'est une tête
de pont commercial excellente vers le
proche orient et les pays de l'est avec
qui la grèce pratique de nombreux
échanges les communistes français voit
l'histoire autrement que ce que je vous
en ai dit tout à l'heure pour l'humanité
giscard en grèce c'est le cheval de
troie supranationale et georges marchais
à toulouse a dénoncé les dangers de
l'élargissement une nouvelle fois il a
dénoncé les dangers de l'élargissement
du marché commun l'humanité le journal
l'humanité souligne également
l'opposition du parti communiste du
parti socialiste grec à cette adhésion
de leur pays
georges marchais avait d'ailleurs
adressé une lettre à monsieur giscard
d'estaing pour lui demander de ne pas
signer ce traité d'adhésion
réponse du président de la république à
georges marchais vous connaissez les
règles vous méconnaissez pardon les
règles constitutionnelles
je ne vais pas at elle signé un traité
comme vous l'écrivez de façon innée
acte mais pour manifester par ma
présence en tant que président en
exercice du conseil européen
l'importance de l'adhésion grecque
ensuite le gouvernement français
veillera
comme tous les autres d'ailleurs pays à
soumettre à son parlement le texte de
l'accord d'adhésion pour lui demander
d'en délibérer et de se prononcer par un
vote
alors c'est ici que tout naturellement
vient le débat en france sur les
élections
le journal des européennes avec le
service politique de tf1
rencontre en fin d'après midi à paris
entre le secrétaire général du parti
communiste georges marchais et un
certain nombre d'intellectuels qui ont
appelé à voter pour la liste du pc le 10
juin prochain parmi ces intellectuels le
contestataire jeunes jetaient le nouveau
président d'allemagne fédérale carreaux
carstens à tf1 l'élargissement
progressif des compétences du parlement
européen serait à la fois juste et
conséquent jean françois poncet sur rmc
les opinions des grandes familles
politiques français sur la façon de
construire l'europe se sont rapprochés
georges sarre socialiste le parti
communiste se sert de l'europe et des
revendications légitimes des
travailleurs pour faire prévaloir ses
intérêts de boutique
andré diligent centristes de l'udf nous
ne sommes pas les partisans du tout ou
rien l'europe politique sera la plus
grande démocratie de la planète après
toulon et annecy raymond barre à autun
en saône et loire pour sa troisième
réunion européenne parlant sous les
portraits du général de gaulle de
georges pompidou et de valéry giscard
d'estaing
le premier ministre a mis l'accent sur
la continuité de la politique européenne
de son gouvernement
on a osé me reprocher d'avoir parlé
devant les portraits du général de
gaulle de monsieur pompidou et de
monsieur giscard d'estaing on a inventé
des raisons
curieuse est il exact pour lesquelles je
n'avais pas le droit de le faire
je n'ai pas besoin de vous dire que
j'accueille tout cela avec la plus
parfaite indifférence et le plus grand
mépris et je remercie les organisateurs
je n'ai pas en ce qui me concerne la
capacité d'oubli dont certains autres
font preuve par rapport aux
responsabilité qu'ils ont assumée dans
le passé ce que je viens vous dire ce
soir c'est que le gouvernement français
que j'ai l'honneur de diriger poursuit
la politique européenne qui a été mise
en heure dans l'intérêt de la france
depuis 1950
cette politique européenne elle a été
menée avec continuité par les mêmes
hommes par des hommes qui ont été les
ministres du général de gaulle les
ministres de monsieur pompidou et moi un
niveau plus modeste
j'ai servi aussi les deux présidents de
la république dans cette construction
continue qu'a été la communauté
européenne
le centre d'information civique contre
les appelle à l'abstention pour le 10
juin vouloir l'abstention n'est ni
défendable ni sérieux dit il c'est
trahir la démocratie il est inacceptable
que l'on aux conseillers ou organiser la
désertion des urnes
alain krivine numéro deux de la liste
pour les états unis socialistes d'europe
le marché commun actuel est une
association de brigands jean louis
tixier vignancour a présenté cet après
midi la liste de l'union française de
l'euro droite constitué par le parti des
forces nouvelles pour la défense des
intérêts français dans l'europe la
création d'un exécutif européen est
contre l'avortement
michel de saint pierre qui conduisait
une liste de rassemblement de la droite
française avait dû renoncer mercredi
dernier faute de moyens financiers
ce trésor les gens de droite la droite
sont franches étaient ravis de la
constitution de cette liste et la
culture lever les moyens dont elle
briguait pas les moyens et qu'ils ne
pourraient pas voter pour une liste
correspondant à l'orge opinion politique
générale
là ça a été un sursaut extraordinaire et
en 10 ou 12 heures nous avons reçu de
quoi pouvoir poursuivre ce que j'appelle
le plan orsec
c'est à dire la campagne est mal
c'est-à-dire les bulletins de vote et
les affiches et je vous donne un chiffre
en 12 heures sont arrivés 172 millions
de santé d'après vous qui semblez
électeurs dont j'avais peur sensuelle
qui reste fidèle à comme on l'a dit une
certaine idée de la france mais moi je
préfère à une certaine image de la
france
partie intégrante de l'europe le par son
passé par son courage et aussi le lou
rihon propre tête par sa culture
enfin début demain 19h42 la campagne
officielle télévisée du nouveau studio
aménagé la maison de la radio
s'exprimeront successivement et pour
cinq minutes chacune
les listes de jacques chirac françois
mitterrand georges marchais et simone
veil
cette campagne officielle prendra fin le
8 juin au soir
une information dite sociale si le cnpf
et les centrales syndicales ne
parviennent pas à se mettre d'accord à
l'issue de la négociation qui va
s'ouvrir mercredi qui sera longue et
difficile sur l'aménagement de la durée
du travail est bien le gouvernement
déposera un projet de loi pour réduire
la durée hebdomadaire maximum je dis
bien maximum du travail de 48 heures à
40 6 heures c'est andré bergeron de
force ouvrière qui l'a annoncé ce matin
après un entretien avec le premier
ministre
je vous rappelle que la durée légale du
travail est actuellement de 40 heures
par semaine et vous savez qu'il ya un
débat à l'échelle européenne pour la
réduire progressivement à 35 heures pour
l'instant la durée légale et donc de 40
heures mais par le moyen des heures
supplémentaires une entreprise a le
droit de faire travailler 48 heures au
maximum
c'est ce plafond qu'il s'agirait d'
abaisser à 46 eur on estime que moins de
40% des salariés de l'industrie font des
heures supplémentaires
les autres nouvelles de ce journal avec
vous tout burg a aucun mobile dans le
meurtre des deux petites filles près de
lyon le garçon de 20 ans qui est passé
sans difficulté aux aveux la nuit
dernière a expliqué qu'il avait
rencontré par hasard les deux enfants
sur un terrain vague où il venait cachée
du matériel volé après avoir parlé
quelques minutes avec elle les a tués à
l'aide à l'aide d'une sorte de gourdins
c'est un véritable conseil de famille
d'ailleurs se doutant de quelque chose
qui a prévenu la police
à orange en revanche on sait que c'est
le racisme qui a tué après un incident
dans la rue avec des marchands ambulants
africain trois frères âgés d'une
trentaine d'années sont allés mettre le
feu à l'hôtel où logeait ces africains
en quelques secondes le bâtiment fut
embrasé deux hommes sont morts
carbonisés trois autres ont été
sérieusement brûlés les trois frères
rapidement identifié par la police on
expliqué je cite leurs propos c'est les
[ __ ] qui nous ont cherché une affaire
aussi lamentable dimanche soir dans la
banlieue parisienne pour régler un
différend pécuniaire deux hommes ont
joué au western dans la cour d'un
pavillon pendant plusieurs minutes
embusqué dans des portes cochères ils se
sont affrontés à coups de pistolet
tirant sur tout ce qui bougeait les deux
forcenés sont grièvement blessés mais
ils ont atteint aussi une troisième
personne la police a dû à son tour aussi
sortir ses armes pour les séparer on a
appris en fin d'après-midi la mort
de monsieur georges dayan monsieur dayan
membre du comité directeur du parti
socialiste sénateur de paris était un
ami très proche de françois mitterrand
négociations toujours dans une impasse
totale à san salvador où l'ambassade de
france est en état de siège l'envoyé du
gouvernement français est rentré samedi
à paris sans résultat il avait obtenu
l'asile politique au panama pour les
révolutionnaires mais ces derniers
entendent rester au pays
le couple ou x plane relève la tête
depuis quelques mois aux états unis et
tout particulièrement dans son fief
l'état d'alabama les membres du club ont
repris plusieurs fois leurs cérémonies
lugubre depuis le début de l'année dans
de petites villes de cet état du sud
ces manifestations déclenché à leur tour
la réplique des noirs et cela se termine
généralement violente bagarre de rue au
cours du week-end et le week-end dernier
cela s'est très mal passé trois
personnes ont été grièvement blessées au
cours d'affrontements qui ont duré plus
de 24 heures tout a commencé par une
marche de protestation des noirs les
membres du ku klux klan outre intercepté
la manifestation un coin de rue et ont
tout simplement ouvert le feu les noirs
ont riposté
on a relevé des blessés dans les deux
camps la transat en double en tête par
rapport à la distance restant à
parcourir premier jean-claude par isis
sur fernande derrière lui le jeune
riguidel sur vsd le trimaran des sd qui
est un trimaran ensuite kersauson sur
critères 6 tabarly est 11e et brittany
ferries avec notre confrère stéphane
magnier et 15e météo très difficiles
avec des vents contraires ce placement
est il faut le rappeler très provisoire
le jury femina célèbre cette année son
75e anniversaire il vient d'attribuer
son prix va caresco 79 destiné à
récompenser un essai à claude vigée pour
un ouvrage qui s'appelle l'art et le
démoniaque publié chez flammarion le
temps et bien tout de même ça s'est
arrangé ce lundi dans toute la france
est températures sont devenus plus
agréable en début d'après midi elle
était comprise entre 13° en bretagne et
28 degrés au pays basque et demain alors
le de la vendée au pas de calais les
nuages resteront abondants avec quelques
plus intermittentes mais ce sera juste
localisés comme vous le voyez là sur
toutes les autres régions le
temps sera bien ensoleillé malgré
quelques nuages passagers et les
températures seront plus élevées que
celles d'aujourd'hui
si j'en crois l'équipe et d'autres
spécialistes sportifs le tournoi des
internationaux de france le tournoi de
roland garros qui a commencé aujourd'hui
sous le soleil avec des tribunes combles
sera le meilleur depuis dix ans toutes
les grandes vedettes seront là de borg
vilas en passant par connor manquera
seulement mcenroe
l'américain et cela pour cause de
blessure mais il était aujourd'hui à
paris au moment où s'ouvrait le tournoi
avec notamment les français goven domine
gouez et proisy goven a été battu par
l'italien aux clefs pau en quatre sets
et patrice dominguez a éliminé patrick
proisy en quatre sets
ce tournoi sera l'événement sportif en
france pendant quinze jours
ce week-end l'événement il ne fallait
pas aller chercher en tout cas dans la
finale du championnat de france de rugby
on ne peut pas tout faire à la fois se
battre comme des chiffonniers faire un
beau match narbonne le champion méritait
mieux pour son image de marque
en revanche l'événement c'était le grand
prix de monaco le brio des ferrari la
victoire de sectaire la grande place de
la fille tel panache de de payet pour
les ligier et dans cette course
passionnante les héros malheureux n'ont
pas manqué au milieu du cimetière des
voitures
il faut sans doute aussi salué le
courage de toute l'équipe renault
rendez-vous à dijon il dit dans un mois
pour le grand prix de france reste un
autre événement sportif qui s'achève
aujourd'hui
la fantastique victoire de bernard
hinault dans le dauphiné libéré lui
aussi porte le maillot renault et il a
été une véritable formule 1 du vélo
comme s'il avait un triple turbo dans
les jambes un triple turbo qui ne lâche
pas de temps en temps aujourd'hui
bernard hinault dossard 87 a
naturellement gagner l'étape
contre-la-montre 36 km autour du lac
d'annecy c'est sa spécialité
vous le voyez ici rejoindre l'ubs erding
le second au classement général le
rejoindre et bientôt le dépasser bernard
hinault remporte donc le dauphiné libéré
mais ce qu'on retiendra surtout c'est
l'extraordinaire étape d'hier qui pour
jean-michel leulliot est un véritable
morceau d'anthologie dans le sport
cycliste et jean-michel leniaud sait ce
que valent les mots dimanche sur le 100
km et quatre cols sous une pluie
battante ils ont tous crié grâce hotmail
frigorifié franchissant la ligne avec 19
minutes de retard requinqué dans les
derniers kilomètres grâce à un bidon de
whisky sont dues par son directeur
sportif jean pierre danguillaume grand
mime le petit écureuil forcé à la
retraite anticipée paralysée au point de
ne plus pouvoir guider sa machine dans
les descentes de cole cuyper chaos à 25
minutes et bien d'autres encore tous
sont plus berling jeune hollandais
fringants qui a connu le déshonneur cet
après-midi d'être rejoint par le breton
dans le dernier contre-la-montre
d'annecy
mais la supériorité de bernard hinault
s'explique par plusieurs réseaux une
remarquable préparation choisissant la
décompression nécessaires avant les
grands rendez vous un entraînement très
dur et judicieux il fut le seul à
reconnaître les cols du dauphiné avant
la course et au rythme de la course afin
d'habituer son organisme aux petits
bracket
un programme bien équilibré fruit de
l'organisation du maître tacticien qui
est cyrille guimard
une volonté qui se lit sur son visage
reflétant la rage de vaincre
l'orgueil nécessaire du champion et
enfin le bénéfice de l'âge il a 7 ans de
moins que ses grands adversaires battus
hier dans le peloton on le baptise le
blaireau le dictionnaire indique animal
de formes massives actif toute l'année
qui provoque de très sérieux dommages
c'est une excellente définition
voilà et rendez vous avec lino sans
doute dans le tour de france et à
l'arrivée dernier journal maurice
olivari vers 23h merci de votre
attention merci au nom de toute l'équipe
de tf1 actualité